there's a this great distinction between
giving offense and taking offense and
we're living in a culture where people
become experts in taking offense yes
even when it hasn't been given and
that's what is taught in gender studies
yes it teaches young women to take
offense at every remark a man might make
or even his being there you know it's a
it's a wonderful theatrical thing to
take offense but it doesn't lead to any
lasting relationships
at the scrutin Murray college it will be
illegal to take gender studies
because of course it isn't of course
this is a problem with a lot of these
so-called social sciences they're not
Sciences they're not they're not
actually a discipline it's just a
political indoctrination to make people
bitter than they were when they went in